bootleg cat podcast special guest in
here from Merced California
representing the homie GB
yes sir yes sir welcome man appreciate
it man I appreciate the invite yeah I've
been uh checking you out for a minute
man I want to say I first saw you uh
maybe like a year year and a half ago on
um it's probably on the thizzler page
probably to be honest shout out to them
uh and I just been seeing you [ __ ]
leveling up doing your thing for a
minute man so salute to you appreciate
it uh being from Merced is like um
it's obviously a a city in Cali a lot of
people don't know about it's it's uh
like you said it's between what Modesto
and Stockton you said uh now we're right
between uh Modesto and Fresno Modesto
and Fresno yeah so it's kind of like um
you know it's like one of those cities
that like is like a drive-through City
they call right people just drive
through right what's it like being from
there and like trying to make it as a
rapper bro I mean it's it's it's
difficult coming out from a from a town
that nobody's ever heard of you know
what I'm saying I'm sure people might
have heard about it drove through it or
something but there's not really coming
out of there yeah so it's dope it's a
dope experience just experiencing uh you
know people hearing about it uh and and
just putting it out there is pretty dope
they put a cookies there yet
in Merced we got a burner's Merced ah
burner shout out berners Merced for so I
was just there yesterday um
yeah they couldn't name I don't think
they could have name yeah because it was
probably one close there's like a
certain like a radius like if they open
a cookie somewhere if if the next town
over once when it's got to be like a
burners or a lemonade no I know what it
is yeah yeah yeah possible so there's a
burners in Merced burner's Mercedes shut
up burners so that's like the big
dispensary out there yeah we got four
dispensaries I believe
um but yeah that's that's that'll be the
go-to for me uh for you uh what would
you consider like for you you know
you're obviously independent artist
you're on the come up like what would be
the time or the moment that you've
really figured out that like you might
be able to do this rap [ __ ] full time
like it might work out for you you know
what I mean I never knew I could the
moment I decided to do that was um when
I went to prison this last time uh I
couldn't really find a a reason behind
me being in prison like I knew I was
[ __ ] up but uh
I was like what I'm gonna do with this
time is I'm just gonna try to rap for me
I always wanted a rap since I was a kid
I just never knew I could
um and we never had like Studios like
you know like La in the bay yeah there's
Studios everywhere yeah so we didn't
have that out there obviously so it
seemed like impossible you feel me to
ever you feel me uh
record a song so when I was in in prison
this last time I was in in there with a
lot of different talent and uh they
would have ciphers and go back and forth
spit on the tier and stuff like that and
uh you know majority of them were black
right so when I was like man let me get
in on this Cipher they looked at me like
you're getting crazy yeah like what the
[ __ ] are you gonna talk about right but
then I started spitting and I would keep
up with them you know I mean they'll be
like damn you got bars so then I'm
thinking like all right I should
probably try it out when I get out so
when you got out you were like you kind
of put your battery in your back like
you were working on the craft while you
were incarcerated right yeah yeah I
didn't do it right when I got out
because I was on probation and my PO
wouldn't let me make music because
really yeah because it was considered
Gang Related
yeah so anything I would say would be
considered game related little closer to
the mic bro oh yeah
yeah so everything I would say would be
uh considered gang related to my PO
and even then they still try to use it
you know like and other things but
um
once I was off of the papers with that I
was like yeah let's let's go I'll win it
let's go crazy yeah is there like I mean
obviously Northern California is a way
different Beast than Southern California
when it comes to like the gangs [ __ ] the
politics [ __ ] like when it comes to a
small town like that like is it is it
more the reason why people get involved
with that [ __ ] because there's really
not a lot to do
because I always hear people from small
cities they're like man we get wrapped
up in [ __ ] because we're bored not
necessarily it's all really like the
environment you grow up around and the
people you you decide to hang around
with you for me
um sometimes you know it doesn't really
leave you much of a choice or because
there's people that that are in the hood
that don't gangbang of course of course
um
but [ __ ] I would just say it you know
there's a lot of similar
similar you know activities you know
people die everywhere people die all the
time they get killed a lot of people go
to jail everywhere not just you know
certain cities but I feel it's very
similar how long were you uh
incarcerated the last time this last
time I believe like a year and some
change maybe like I took three years
what happened for a pistol yeah [ __ ]
yeah and when you got out was this what
what year were you did you like
initially get out I got out 2000
I believe it was two thousand seventeen
damn so you're pretty like full-time
rapping it's pretty you know it's a
pretty new like you're not like it's
like you've been doing this for like
[ __ ] 10 years like a lot of people
yeah nah I started actually making music
2018. damn seriously it's been working
out for you man it's grind yeah it's
just you gotta grind I was gonna say
like what what like for people who are
watching this like uh
you know I do feel like that that
Northern Cali that Northern Central Cali
hustle's different than everywhere else
in the country when it comes to just rap
[ __ ] like what were the some of the
things you were doing that you noticed
were paying off like in terms of getting
fans getting traction uh just
consistency consistency and uh
networking
um there's only so far you could get in
in one town or in one section you
eventually you know like lately I've
been moving uh doing a lot of things out
here yeah I haven't seen you out here
yet yeah so
um just you know networking you know I
mean uh collaborating
uh trying you know just trying to find a
way up until this point it's really been
trial and error so
uh you know if it don't work we're just
gonna try to do another one yeah keep
putting up shots exactly yeah if
someone's got a hit that's what Russell
will be saying the Russell's like man I
put up a thousand shots she's like yeah
the Russell's been going crazy you've
been going crazy on my timeline he's
been killing me yeah for sure uh what do
you got out right now man what's like
the latest that you're pushing what do
you got coming [ __ ] I got a couple of
music videos in the vault right now uh
dropping sometime soon
I'm working on an album right now too uh
probably be a little EP and I honestly
just really just
just trying to just trying to hit it in
all different directions no I think I
saw you on there that I remember I think
it was Dave o
J's manager I want to say might have
reposted your [ __ ] possibly shout out
davo I I ran into him out here before I
feel like he might have posted you on
his story yeah shout out Mozzy too I
mean I [ __ ] with everybody yeah all type
of rappers yeah
um well [ __ ] man uh we're gonna have you
just get to it you know what I'm saying
you pulled out I appreciate you coming
out here for this yeah you said that you
uh you had lost your keys it's a tough
feeling yeah for sure I was stressful
because I was like man I'm stressed out
but we here man yeah yeah we made it
Merced is in the building GB is in the
building and he's here to drop off some
bars so let's get to it man come on
hey why the app is in the city man I'm
the greatest thing that the city had
since Paperboy had to Diddy dance [ __ ]
if it's really that y'all can have it
back I ain't even cat like why even rap
I took a trip and made the blicky jam
for I got the chance to go to Disneyland
since 0-3 I stuck the 50s plan get rich
or die trying we ain't plenty grams the
type of [ __ ] that'll get you hated by
many men mobbing in the minivan to see
how we been sliding Free Willy free Rex
free solid yeah and Fritos keeping
silence I would say other names but I
ain't trying to get indicted watch what
you say when you fighting open cases
then they got you wondering how I end up
in them cages now you got your lyrics on
statements in affidavits I'm just saying
I'd rather be Freedom be famous I just
left court Laura trying to get the time
right back on the road I'm just trying
to get my mom right R.I.P nib taught me
how to get my ground right and I ain't a
mama the only things in my eyesight feel
me yeah keep going keep going keep going
man keep going one second come on man
let me look
look yeah I grew up off of beans and
rice listening in the park before I knew
I had a read and write hella years later
hit the county in my green and whites
yeah and now it's really hard to sleep
at night life would be so treated right
cause that [ __ ] could really take you
far and even then
[Music]
I had it it's good it's good it's good
yes sir bootleg cab yeah GB Merced let's
get it hey you just watched a crazy
freestyle and we drop one every week
sometimes more than once a week uh and
they're always presented by our family
at LRG now I love LRG I'm wearing look
I'm gonna just show you the new shorts I
got from them check out them shorts my
boy you know what I'm saying and got the
plain black tea the plain black lrgt you
know what I mean listen lrg's back they
just dropped the crazy Jason hoodie with
Jadakiss that's from like 2008 for
Halloween [ __ ] Flames go to the
website
l-r-g.com and this is crazy because
they're giving you thirty percent off
when you use the promo code bootleg
thirty percent off that's a significant
amount of money you're going to be
saving when you go to lrg's website
Christmas is coming save 30 off just by
going to the website and using the promo
code bootleg L Dash R g.com we'll see
you next week with a crazy freestyle